[Musique]
le variant isolé en afrique du sud on
qui est plus résistant et très très
largement prédominant en afrique du sud
alors qu'en france et la pelote tout
être un pour cent des cas on sait qu'il
est plus transmissible
non ne sais pas jusqu'à quel degré on ne
sait pas s'il donne des formes plus
sévères de la maladie et est ce qu'on
sait en revanche c'est qu'il échappe à
l'immunité naturelle et aussi qui répond
moi bien au vaccin
une figure exaspère au sommet de l'état
jean françois delfraissy le président du
conseil scientifique
il faudra aller probablement vers un
confinement
je ne vois pas comment on peut échapper
au confinement mais il faut le souhaiter
une folle et très vite alors là oui il
va falloir se sont assez rapides avec
lui c'est toujours la fin du monde
s'énerve un ministre et d'ajouter qu'est
ce qu'il fout sur les plateaux télé à
son âge il ferait mieux de rester
confiné chez lui comme il l'a recommandé
un autre mythe on peut même imaginer
qu'on va vivre des années avec mais on
les a avec oui on aura une structure on
aura une organisation de dépistage de
traçage et ça veut dire qu'il va
peut-être falloir attendre des mois
comptant pas là non non non moi je me
place dans des situations dans un dans
une perspective de quelques jours sans
doute pas parce qu'on va attendre les
chiffres un proche du président imagine
le futur sort de ces scientifiques
quand ce sera fini ils seront balayés
les français ne voudront plus les voir
une prédiction encore incertaine tout
comme le pari de ne par confiner
officiellement l'elysée reste prudent et
appelle à la vigilance
nous sommes toujours sur le même plateau
au même si il apparaît légèrement
déclinant depuis une semaine
il existe bien un chemin pour éviter
leur confinement ce chemin n'est pas
large mais il existe il est possible
qu'on ne soit jamais recombiner vous y
croyez vous ces bonnes nouvelles
si c'est le cas une bonne nouvelle c'est
une institution qui vacille depuis
quelques jours sciences po est dans la
tourmente
les témoignages de viols et agressions
sexuelles se multiplient sous le hashtag
science port des étudiants ou anciens
étudiants raconte leur histoire
douloureuse et l'omerta qui régnerait le
directeur de sciences po paris emporté
par la sphère duhamel fredericlyon
démissionne de son poste les étudiants
faisait pression depuis que la faire
avec l'ani lui reprocher de dire qu'il
ne savait pas alors qu'il avait a
reconnu avoir été alerté en 2018 par
aurélie filippetti l'ancien ministre de
la culture enseignante à sciences po
le compte à rebours est enclenché il va
falloir avoir un homme ou une femme qui
incarne le parti mais avant de savoir si
c'est pierre paul jacques ou valéry ou
d'autres il apporte de nous retrouver
ses plus hauts près totalement les
jeunes expriment c'est ça moi et je
n'engage que moi alors justement née à
quinze mois de l'élection présidentielle
n'y a pas de candidat qui se détache pas
de primaires annoncé est ce qu au fond
de vous vous avez renoncé il ya une
chose à laquelle je n'ai pas renoncé
c'est à faire prévaloir mes idées est ce
que je remarque c'est que aujourd'hui il
y a un vrai espace eric zemmour
penserait pas seulement en se rasant à
se lancer dans la course à la
présidentielle
en tout cas elle en parle ouvertement à
ses proches
xavier bertrand le président de la
région de france est convaincue que
zemmour a une idée derrière la tête
devant la justice aujourd'hui la
présidente du rassemblement national
marine le pen et l'eurodéputé gilbert
collard ils sont jugés pour avoir
diffusé des photos d'exactions du groupe
etat islamique sur les réseaux sociaux
en 2015 les médias les publie les
éditorialistes les publient les journaux
les publie
les télévisions les publier et que
personne n'a jamais été poursuivi de ce
fait il n'y a que marine le pen qui est
poursuivi et bien dans ces conditions là
on peut je crois en tirer la conclusion
que je suis évidemment victime d'un
procès politique et à la d'ailleurs des
mots très ironique au sujet d'eric
zemmour dans ce papier à son sujet il
lui a il m'est arrivé de dire il ya
vouloir et pouvoir
moi quand j'étais jeune je voulais être
miss france